okay let's get into hatred mail for the
week if you're not familiar with hatred
mail this is what hatred mail is the
[Music]
right of the people to keep and bear
hates shall not be infringed Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom so we've had a lot of different
types of Patriot mail over the last
couple of years but there are a few
themes that are sort of old faithful we
can always go back to them one is of
course homophobia and another is
anti-semitism and that's where we are
today let's take a listen to this week's
hey treat male boys where's the yarmulke
this Jew talk only works on Israelis the
truth Jew lull nice try [ __ ] to just
smile and go to church it's no big deal
IQ by race is it's of Ashkenazi the
Pakman show is funded by the Clinton
Foundation yeah listen it's it's bad out
there and the anti-semitism has
definitely been emboldened by the rise
of the alt-right
in connection with the Trump
administration this is probably I think
the first time I've been called [ __ ]
and hey okay I think yeah I mean if
you're only listening you should really
check this out on YouTube because you
gotta see the dictation the punctuation
on this one that's right yeah I was like
to open parenthesis and then three
clothing oh yeah yeah it's it's it's
mathematically impossible we are that's
right if you only listen to hatred mail
if you watch patriot mail there's a
read-along transcript exactly as written
by the hatred and that you really need
that to fully do justice to the
atrocities that are committed
grammatically in hatred man I like the
more than signs it kind of like flows
one thing to the next yeah there's a
greater than or less than sign I guess
depending on which way you're reading or
something like that
turn hatred mail into something positive
the coupon code hey tree at forty gets
you forty percent off at the membership
of your choice at david pakman.com slash
membership that's h80 r io t four zero